leute herzlich willkommen zur nächsten
folge minecraft maus wir nähern uns dem
ende letzte folge bei luca ist soviel
passiert wir haben ewigkeiten
aufgenommen lukat es extrem zusammen
schneiden müssen und diese folge werden
wir in den neckar gehen warum wir wollen
dort ein bisschen level sammeln und
falls ihr euch fragt was macht dieses
riesige papier steht auf meinem namen
vielleicht habe es ein paar schon
erwarten wir spielen wer bin ich
also du bist auch dabei ich dachte du
wirst jetzt etwas sagen ja wir spielen
hier bin ich wie ich wusste gleich dass
du den zettel schon in die in der
schnauze kleben hat ihn typischen auf
gerade mal eben hin also soll ich mal
ganz gut an die kämen gehen damit die
leute sehen was das was er zeigt mein
name ok macht man es jetzt auch gesehen
sonst wenn es der name unscheinbar als
der name ist ein bisschen komisch dann
kannst du dann nachher nochmal
vielleicht in der felskante
unterschreiben habe ich glaube das läuft
ja glaub ich auch leute ihr habt gerade
gesehen minecraft ist schon wieder
gecrasht so wie es aussieht ist es
leider nicht anders möglich kommen jetzt
die nächsten folgen von minecraft
mazzone shader bei mir zumindest bei
luca kommen sie ganz normal mit shader
weiterhin ich muss jetzt einfach aus
meinem pc ist leider einfach zu schwach
dafür wir sind uns glaube ich beide
einig dass wir jetzt im netter nicht
groß auf entdeckungstour gehen sondern
wirklich einfach mal rum laufen so ein
bisschen nachfolge so ein bisschen
erkunden aber jetzt ohne großes ziel
oder ja also wir wollen halt schon
angekündigt hast du genug essen dabei
ich habe vier gebratenes hammelfleisch
oben in der doppelt ist noch ein
bisschen was ich gehe was holen ganz
neue regeln von wer bin ich wir fragen
gegenseitig fragen über die person die
der andere auf dem kopf stehen hat wenn
sie richtig ist dürfen wir weiter fragen
wenn es falsch ist ist der nächste dran
wären wir jetzt ins portal gehen ich
fange einfach mal an ich frage bin ich
männlich jap bin ich ein berühmt wobei
das ist okay das direkt eine festung wir
fahren jetzt einfach netter quarz genau
da genau damit mit pawel kind bin ich
ein minecraft youtuber ich würde sagen
das ist vorsicht vorsicht da geht es
sehr sehr weit runter luca vogel runter
hier vorsicht nicht daran ihn einfach
was nur lava überall junge das einfach
die pure hölle da die richtig wir haben
jetzt die lücke versagen
teils teils minecraft youtuber kenne ich
max diese person persönlich persönlich
ja ich weiß es nicht ich würde sagen ich
dachte mal einfach ja ich bin nicht
hundertprozentig sicher
also sichern seien vom paar jahren oder
so mal aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht
sicher ist diese person gerade in
unserer aufnahme
nein jetzt dein ernst computer das ist
der älteste trick aller zeiten sich
selbst zu nehmen ist es konkreter nein
verdammt okay jetzt hast du jetzt hast
du einen anlauf luca ok wo bist du
eigentlich überhaupt gerade ich bin noch
in der nähe vom anfang aber du hast
gerade direkt vor mir also halb so wild
okay bin ich männlich bin ich habe ich
über 100.000 abonnenten ja bin ich
deutscher youtuber ja alle wenn ich das
jetzt gehören wir dann das wird zu krank
dass er zu krank habe ich über 500.000
abonnenten
das muss mir ganz kurz checken aber ich
denke nein das wäre es natürlich gewesen
also habe ich echt nicht abgesprochen
das ist kompletter zufall dass nicht
über 500.000 okay ich bin also du darfst
noch ein zwei fragen mehr stellen
ok ich sage zwei fragen gebe ich dir
noch zwei mal falsch dazu noch zweimal
fall schafft noch am max weber überhaupt
gerade erst mal hin einfach irgendwie ne
backwards suchen
also ich war was könnte ich dann noch
fragen
bin ich lade ich gaming hoch nein
leidig unterhaltungs videos hoch bin ich
bei einem netzwerk partner sicher junge
alter geht das hier weit runter
ehrlich ich habe richtig angst hier in
der wüste las ich habe auch übel angst
ich habe ja gar nicht richtig
konzentrieren
du hast noch eine einzige frage ja aber
ich bin sauer schlecht denn so was also
ich würde sagen bin ich bin ich bei
mache ich teil habe ich schon mal ein
musik video hochgeladen
ja das ist eine gute frage gewesen sei
was könnte ich dann noch fragen habe ich
bin ich über mich mögen mich die youtube
mag mich die youtube community
nein gott wenn er wenig dass jetzt noch
verliere habe ich
bin ich ein lifestyle youtube ja lasse
ich mich oft von einem kanadischen
künstler inspirieren
ja bitte nicht bin ich finde ich für
jede park mitbürger nein bist du mich du
bist du ganz gemacht aber machen
lifestyle da gehört es ist doch mal
ausschließen können eheleute okay dann
bin ich jetzt dran bin ich krank crafter
ja du bist bist du okay wir sehen die
dinge ab ok jetzt konzentriert zwar ein
bisschen dass wir noch im bereich hat
nicht jeder dass er so schnell geht das
echt krass gewinnen wir können kein
wasser setzen überrascht mich jedes
verfehlt haben wir keinen fragen luca
wir müssen hier irgendwie runter ja auf
jeden fall
ich weiß nicht wie ich auch nicht junge
wie riskant alleine unsere wege hier
schon sind zu über stock und stein durch
irgendwie wo bist du jetzt gerade
eigentlich als ich meinen namen hörte
war ich glaube ich habe eine idee wo wir
irgendwie hin können
das ist jetzt halt megawatt leute wir
fahren einfach noch ein ganz bisschen
weiter an der dass wir noch ein paar
level kriegen jetzt auf jeden fall
wollen wir einfach noch eine runde
spielen
wir könnten theoretisch vorrundenspiel
mein ding ist ein bisschen alle aber so
ich habe meinen youtuber auf einem
zettel notiert schmeißt man diesen
zettel jetzt auf die stirn ich gehe mal
ganz kurz an das ding dran damit ihr
seht konnte man jetzt ein bisschen sehen
also von mir aus darf ich anfange der
ersten frage kern ja okay bin ich
weiblich ich habe ihm ist ein netter
festung gefunden magst du bist weiblich
lade ich regelmäßig videos hoch habe ich
über 500.000 abonnenten
mal kurz nachschauen die frage ist wie
wir jetzt darunter kommen ja ja du hast
du hast über 500.000 abonnenten
lade ich die videos hoch ja okay das ist
bei frauen irgendwie klar bin ich ein
umstrittener kanal
ja ich will ich würde schon sagen habe
ich einen bin ich in einer beziehung ja
macht mein freund ebenfalls
youtube-videos also jetzt indirekt im
sinne ob er selbst auf dem kanal
betreibt für sich selbst nie ob er an
musikvideo ob er arbeiten berater was
ich dort bin ich da gebieten eine
verdammt ich dachte wegen freund eugen
ja okay dann bin ich dran
ok luca brauchst du hier ein bisschen
weiter dann können wir endlich runter
gleich entwickler solcher weiterbauen
einfach hier dass wir da vorne runter
können aber klar wie sie auch schon
vorne war vorne weg schon übrigens leute
dass die folge ein bisschen ruhiger ist
also wir sind wie gesagt schon seit
stunden am aufnehmen nur damit dieses
projekt im rahmen des möglichen liegt
und deswegen entschuldigt dies bisher
nicht böse gemeint oder sowas sondern
wir sind einfach wirklich ziemlich
ziemlich angst regeln dass wir das für
euch hinbekommen aber ist scheint so als
würden wir hinbekommen und aus dem grund
denke ich mal könnt ihr uns das
verzeihen so ich bin dran bin ich ein
wenig ein junge
für mädchen okay ja berater fragen also
in die ich bin rande
es war ein direkt okay bin ich dann noch
fragen
mädchen beauty videos kenne ich diese
person persönlicher tja und hast du holz
weil ich habe keine spitzhacke mehr
ich habe noch eine hier kenne ich diese
personen persönlich schon mal getroffen
habe
ja denke ich mal du hast ja die meisten
youtuber schon mal getroffen
also ob ich mit denen jetzt so auch
schon mal so kontakt hatte irgendwie
also so von wegen ja schon mal
unterhalten und das kann ich nicht genau
sagen das weiß ich nicht genau ob du
dich schon unterhalten erst mit der das
weiße nicht okay
[Musik]
ich tue mich gerade richtig schwer dabei
ich weiß ich weiß ich habe gerade eine
kiste gefunden was man bei diamanten mit
einer goldenen pferde rüstung und mit
eisen ohne ist eben meine nächste frage
ich mache jetzt mal was was klipp und
klar das habe ich über eine millionen
abonnenten
ja ja ja ich denke die ganze zeit an
eine youtube drin aber ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass sieht es ist dass
du sie genommen hast irgendwie aber über
eine million ich weiß nicht wie lina
nähten falsch
sie macht ja auch keine beauty videos ja
ja ja auch schon erfolg vielleicht wer
weiß ich glaube es ist hast du für fast
gestorben
dann bin ich jetzt dran ja gut bin ich
männlich ledig kommst du dir moment ich
hab gefragt bin ich weiblich und bin ich
ähnlich du bist weiblich habe ich war
zweimal das gleiche gefragt ich weiß es
nicht aber du bist auf jeden fall
weiblich sagt dass es mal so okay da hab
ich es noch weiter fragen wer fragt mich
noch weiter das gleiche gefragt aber da
gibt es noch weiter fragen wirft hab ich
über 500.000 abonnenten
ja ja ja ich meine ja habe ich einen
freund mit dem ich auch videos machen
nein es wird aber auch sagen leute geben
wir beendeten die folge jetzt sobald wir
den nächsten erraten haben und machen
einfach nächste folge wenn wir oben sind
weiter und rüsten uns aus bin ich babys
bluechip etfs bist du ehrlich weil das
habe ich mich die ganze zeit schon
gefragt weil ich habe mir nur so gedacht
so als du meintest mit ja der freund zu
ob der videos macht ob der wirklich
damit drin ist und ja da habe ich ja
richtig oft auf taggi geführt das war
absicht man weil ich die ganze zeit so
aus steht dann kann es garnicht baby
sein und so
ja ich weiß ich hab dich extra auf taggi
geführt ich rate auch ganz schnell hier
fertig wer du bist machst du beauty
videos nein was zu gaming videos ja
machst du mitmachst schon minecraft
videos nein
hast du über eine million abonnenten ja
bis zum melina ja ok deswegen dachte
auch er ist dass du melina gedacht das
wird total lustig gewesen
egal leute dann scheint es jetzt so als
würden wir diese folge an der stelle
beenden ich hoffe mal sie hat euch
gefallen in der nächsten folge kommen
die finalen vorbereitung auf das ende
von minecraft maus staffel 1 und mach's
gut und bis dahin
hier könnt ihr euch übrigens mein
letztes video anschauen und hier unten
könnt ihr mich abonnieren wenn ihr das
möchte ich sagen sie mir es beim
nächsten mal wieder und tschüss